you're in a Wordle group with Chris's
Silver Linings co-star Bradley Cooper is
this true no I'm trying to get into it
oh you're not and I'm being I'm being
velvet roped by the bouncer here okay
he's telling me that I got I gotta get
like a cooler plus one it's not easy
well we we play this so there's octoidal
which is the eight words and then
chordal which is the four words and then
Wordle which is the one so we play all
three and you add up your score all
right Will Hunting
[Laughter]
no I mean we it's very very competitive
uh uh Will Arnett is in it Bradley
Cooper uh Jason I'm not which is fine
no I advise you you're welcome to join I
just advise you we call it the nerdle
league yeah I was like you can join the
noodle league but you might want to get
your scores down the truth is they told
me what their scores were I was like I
can get in then I did it a couple times
it's like I might need a train